people don't think or talk too much
about architecture about the way their
homes are designed or even their towns
are designed but there is a reason that
things are built the way they are
they're either pro-human or they're
anti-human and unfortunately so much of
our architecture and our city planning
is anti-human andres duwani is one of
the very few urban planners who's
thought deeply about architecture and
planning that brings people together
that makes them happy
he founded the congress for the new
urbanism he's got a plan to build cities
where people might actually know each
other once again we had an amazing
conversation with him on a brand new
episode of tucker carlson today here's
part of it
[Music]
the town plan
it really affects your life for example
um a kid that has to be driven
everywhere is a kid with no freedom at
all you know right and it's and uh an
older person that no longer can drive is
a prisoner highly isolated
so what we design are places that are
walkable above all walkable where you
can get to your daily needs by walking
you could have a car but you don't have
to use it
and i think what makes america pretty
awful is that the car is mandatory yes
if you did not have a car almost as an
individual level every individual has a
car you would literally start to death
in a couple of days you know
and um
we're so used to that that we don't
imagine there's an alternative
and yet up to about 1950 before the cars
were widespread and before everyone
essentially had one
um
every place in right across cultures you
needed your daily needs within walking
distance it was absolutely normal the
romans did it the chinese did it
everybody did it
and then the car eradicated that
discipline